je suis désolé mais je comprends pas
bien le concept du visa v la flash est
fou flash et voilà moi ces trucs que je
regarde les deux portes à vous
d'accord c'est un délai ça ok
bon moi ce que je comprends d'après
votre cv là c'est que vous êtes très
360° bon et nous c'est exactement ce
qu'on recherche
voilà du transversale de l'hybride e
hybride
une autre façon de dire trois postes en
un pays arabe agnel ouais c'est ça on
est moderne
agile surtout en ce qui concerne les
ressources humaines on est bien sharp
on aime bien dynamiter les codes de
l'entretien d'embauché construit trop
gras bon enfin les verts s'étaient quand
j'avais 15 ans ouais c'est clair c'est
clair un café alors moi là j'ai
développé ma propre solution et roche 1
c'est à dire que c'est unique au bronze
ça vient pas des scandinaves
c'est pas les américains c'est français
les français ont du talent est-ce que
vous avez une petite idée de ce qu'on va
faire
oui bah oui ça va ça vous ça vous
déstabilise pas trop parce qu'en fixie
en quoi mon grand père non mon
grand-père beaucoup de père mon grand
père nicolas alors excusez-moi tac c'est
parti alors votre parcours
racontez moi je sais pas s'il est
sûrement rentrer hawks ah oui non vente
ou vendues dont on prononce pas l'unique
sinon je parle de votre parcours
professionnel mademoiselle j'ai un blog
j'écris le mox dont je comprends rien ça
a l'air super mais je comprends
ok vos compétences influence euse
essentiellement dû dire oui aux cimes je
code bien sûr et puis ah oui on a lancé
un dentifrice 0 2 shia qui parraine des
migrants elle est vraiment cool en fait
si j'ai engage quelqu'un de cool tout le
monde me trouvait cool je passe des
disques aussi le coup leva ruisseler sur
moi faut que langage au top tout ça qui
oblige non je pense qu'on est sur un bon
match mais en fait on est clairement sur
une génération qui bouge et fait
rarement la boîte parfaite pour vous et
moi je pense bon que dire sinon oui
alors ici vous avez vu c'est la culture
de l'open space arrive enfin vous
arriver le matin vous vous installez où
vous voulez ça c'est en liberté mais
parce qu'il faut venir
bah oui oui bon il quand même c'est ça
le travail et aller au travail
oui ah non moi je ne reviens pas je suis
plus sur l'instant je dis quoi là non
donc ça vient pas personne sera de fille
cool oui j non on est souple mais enfin
on parle on a un petit peu du poste déjà
au je galère pour la partie
administrative les comptes vous mais ça
ça non mais ça marche pas comme ça à la
comptabilité non mais je viens
concrètement un devis vous savez faire
ça et où je vous parle la vie une app
non écoutez ça va pas le faire
ok c'est l'enfer comme l exige non non
je n'ai pas égalité là aussi vous vous
êtes en mode sénior rabineau non je suis
pas seniors moi je suis enseignant mais
non mais non mais ça n'a rien à voir
vous est très bonne au vélo moi aussi ça
vraiment voilà donc ce travail ça le
fait pas voilà je suis désolé ecoutez
jean peu plus de déchet j'arrange en
peut plus d'être payant paire de baskets
en place de concert j'ai besoin d'un
vrai boulot mais enfin bon je cherche
quelque chose de de plus quand même ok
j'ai compris tout chaud face tu sais pas
s'il faut je peux je peux même venir il
faut non je suis entrain de budget très
cool ça n'est pas le problème
s'il vous plaît je vous reviens mais
c'est comme ça je pourrais d'autres
filles non tu pourrais pas que ma fille
non je suis je suis je suis cool
moi je n'ai pas la faveur des enfants
j'ai l'âge de jouer avec les enfants
déjà je suis pas pédophile j'ai pas dit
ça non j'ai tout simplement voilà je
suis cool je suis un homme enfant voilà
je jubile de soumettre jeu les claques
je suis cool merde ben mouaïa
boulot
alors là on au brésil 1 ou là et gris
mde
[Musique]